[Music]
let's track this from the beginning
start something pure
[Music]
something exciting
then
do some new
told you okay so far you like it
I'm feeling it
yeah
why stop there
[Applause]
this is it
this is the path I started us on
our very strength
invites challenge
Challenge insights conflict
culture
breathe catastrophe
[Music]
the thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts
inevitable
what a sweet-ass run it's been
forces of darkness and light
[Music]
[Applause]
universe now
[Music]
we're continuing the legacy of the MCU
and we're going to do that in new ways
unexpected ways and really build on the
legacy of what's come before
can you move resina No
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie they
just released the trailer from comic-con
for the Avengers infinity Saga it's also
the trailer for their big 23 film box
set they're just calling it the infinity
saga box set that they're releasing
later this year of course I'll do
giveaways for that when it drops all you
have to do to enter that is just be a
subscriber and leave your best Marvel
phase 4 theory on the video they also
released more footage of that Marvel
phase for real that they posted at Comic
Con so it only includes the stuff that
they announced at Comic Con that's why
you don't see a lot of the newer stuff
like new night miss Marvel or she hoped
that they announced at d23 there was
some newer footage in the last week that
leaked out from the Eternals movie
because they're filming that right now
with Angelina Jolie's thena character
just spreading ashes around in a river
it looks like it's happening in ancient
Greece part of that movie will be
flashbacks to ancient history part of it
will take place closer to present day
it'll explain where they were during the
events of all the Marvel phase 1 phase 2
phase 3 movies but I like the way they
opened this trailer with Iron Man's
dialogue they had the four hammer
strikes before the footage picks up just
to denote that we're beginning Marvel
phase four credit where credit is due he
narrates the entire trailer but says
let's track this from the beginning
rewind 10 years to go from the start
this meta commentary about how special
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is and how
no one believed that it would develop
into something as big and grand as it
did this is the path I started us on
because technically this all goes back
to that first Iron Man film you listen
to Kevin Feige talk about it now during
interviews he's like we did not think
that it would be as successful as it was
we hoped that we would be able to do
more movies we never thought that we
would develop this huge cinematic
universe but part of this whole box set
thing the infinity saga that they're
releasing Kevin Feige announced that
they'd be putting a whole bunch of new
bonus features and deleted scenes that
no one had ever seen before he gave us a
taste of that a couple days ago with
that special deleted scene from the
first Ironman post-credit scene with
Nick Fury introducing the Avengers but
mentioning mutants x-men characters in
spider-man years years before we ever
thought we would ever get that stuff in
the MCU mutants weren't enough I have to
deal with a spoiled brat doesn't play
well with others and wants to keep all
his toys to himself a lot of you picked
up on how big
was though because that was still during
tobey maguire era spider-man that was
before Andrew Garfield came along so at
that time when they were teasing
spider-man coming into the MCU with this
Nick Fury post-credit scene they were
thinking about the older version of
spider-man Tobey Maguire coming into the
MCU and because it was before the x-men
first class soft reboot of that
franchise they were talking about the
classic x-men actors talking about Hugh
Jackman Wolverine talking about Patrick
Stewart Professor X coming to the MCU
most of you probably understand why they
couldn't put that in the final cut of
the film that made it in theaters
because they would have been sued out of
existence by Fox and Sony who still held
the rights to those characters now they
can talk about x-men as much as they
want but they're using the Eternals
movie to explain how they can exist
because Nick Fury couldn't just walk in
and say hey look there's a bunch of
x-men because you'd have to explain
where they'd been this entire time so
that's what the Eternals movie is all
about there'll be way more deleted
scenes and bonus features like that
really crazy stuff that they'll drop
later this year is pi gonna happen in
November so I'll do videos for all that
bonus content when it does drop and I
will do giveaways for those big box sets
the Marvel phase 4 footage hyping up all
the new projects that they announced
recently obviously the Hawkeye series
covering the five-year time jump during
Avengers and game when he was Ronan
because there's a whole lot of missing
time there he also probably meets and
rescues Kate Bishop during that period
it also takes place in present day after
Avengers and game when he's training her
Karate Kid mr. Miyagi style to be the
next Hawkeye they announced they're
completing a contract with Hailee
Steinfeld right now to be Kate Bishop
there'll be six episodes but Hailee
Steinfeld who's also spider-gwen in the
Sony spider-verse movies will be in
Avengers five probably crossover to some
of the other earth-based movies and also
be in a Young Avengers project Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness is
all about doing a Marvel horror film and
introducing a broader concept of what
the multiverse looks like in the MCU
nightmare taking advantage of scarlet
witch's reality warping powers using
those to cross through the barrier
between dimensions into our reality and
just wreak havoc I've already talked
about the Eternals movie but the other
cool thing about the Eternals is that
Thanos descends from the Eternals
technically he's a deviant he carries
the deviant gene which is why he looks
the way he does but odds are pretty good
that in one of the Eternals sequels we
will see fan o's being
horn or a very young version of Thanos
in a flashback or in a post-credits
scene I've already done a video about
the Avengers Marvel what if footage
they're doing marbled zombies they're
doing an episode for every single Marvel
movie that means 23 episodes that drops
summer 2021 so still a long ways off but
we'll get footage of it next year the
Loki series will follow tesseract Loki
from Avengers endgame in his alternate
reality as he uses the space stone to
quantum leap through Earth's history
altering the course of events in really
mischievous ways it'll be kind of like
Rick and Morty meets Doctor Who because
Rick and Morty technically don't do
time-traveling by the way that wasn't
time-travel they were just a couple
pizzas on the counter I grabbed him
shanky pretty self-explanatory -
explaining where the real Mandarin of
the MCU has been this whole time why
he's been hiding the ten rings
organization it'll be like the Eternals
movie in that it'll have flashbacks to
ancient history but also present-day
because one of the big twists is
probably that the Mandarin is actually a
title that gets passed down from father
to son and they'll probably change Shang
cheese origin story to make him the son
of the Mandarin of the MCU because in
the comics his father is foo Manchu he's
this really terrible villain that trains
shang-chi to be a weapon of mass
destruction so connecting the dots
Mandarin of the MCU will probably wind
up being his father and it'll be a John
wick style movie where he has to fight
all of his father's men Falcon and
Winter Soldier is pretty
self-explanatory it's all about them
trying to figure out how to carry on the
legacy of Captain America in the shield
when Baron Zemo escapes prison and
starts causing chaos on a global scale
in pursuit of a thunderbolt series it
sounds like Thunderbolts would either be
a Disney Plus series or they could turn
it into a movie
but they have enough characters to do a
big thunderbolt series they have general
Ross Red Hulk that they can do they have
Jelena Bulova Black Widow who's kind of
going to be the black widow of present
day taking the title from the Natasha
Black Widow during that series there
will be a black widow trailer coming by
late November early December and
obviously venom two is getting ready to
film in November so there'll be a whole
bunch of venom and carnage stuff coming
up congratulations Aman who's saying
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details
everybody click here for my Black Widow
teaser and to learn why Iron Man is
coming back during Marvel phase 4 and
click
here to learn all about the big Nova
deleted scene from Avengers infinity war
in Avengers endgame thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]